European election,
deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
zoom on each candidate,
discover the future of a radical left-wing Europe,
Manon aubri and France insoumise,
Léon de Fontaine,
and the French Communist Party,
Nathalie Arto,
and workers' struggle,
environmentalist,
Marie Toussin,
and Europe ecology,
winter,
Jean- governorship and ecology at the center,
Marine Cholet and the Equinox party,
socio-democrat,
Raphaël gluxman and the socialist party,
public square,
William the Cross and the radical left-wing party,
centrists and liberals,
Valerie have,
and the koalition,
rebirth, modem,
horizon
Yes,
François,
Bellami and the Republicans,
nationalist and sovereignist right,
François Asselino and the Republican Popular Union,
Florian and the patriots,
French democratic freedom,
the citizens' party,
for the citizens,
Jordan Bardella,
and the National Rally,
Marion marshal,
and reconquest,
the other parties,
Helen twee,
is the animal rights party,
Jean the room and the rural alliance,
Jean- Fromantin and territories on the move,
Yann Verling and positive ecology and territory,
Laure patas d'illier and Europe democracy,
Esperanto,
Thierry Paul Valet and Fair Europe,
Caroline Zorn is the pirate party,
Philippe Folio is the rural part,
Sven Frank and Volt Europa,
Eve Jernigon is the European federalist party.
On your marks,
ready,
vote,
here we go!